foreign
Texas Remember the Alamo what's up
William
oh good afternoon uh Dave I uh had a
rather unfortunate Financial incident in
in our marriage
happened last fall my wife uh got
victimized in an internet fraud
and not only lost a sizable amount of
cash but also
took out some loans to help these people
and uh some of those were short-term
credit card things like buying gift
cards
and then there were two installment
loans
one was for 23 500.
one was for 17 500.
the rest of them the smaller credit
cards and such
I'm using the snowball method to take
care of those but I need advice on the
installment loans
when it comes to this uh
fraud it's usually one of two things
usually it's some sort of
romantic interest or it's some sort of
somebody crying out for help with
medical assistance or some sort of
Injustice
what is it in your in your in your
situation
uh
it would it would be the former uh
my wife and I have been having been
having some uh problems been together
for 25 years
and uh
things just kind of uh I don't know they
happened and I didn't didn't see the
warning signs
how's your marriage now but
it's it's much better I've been I've
been getting therapy and she has been
too and we've been making some inroads
and just uh basic stuff like how we
speak to each other and I'm proud of you
man that's hard try try it well here's
the thing I I had a bunch of people tell
me
well I would I would divorce somebody
that would do that and I I'm not going
to throw away 25 years
okay I I said I would make a full year
as a concerted effort to get this thing
turned around financially and
emotionally and part of the emotional
thing is me I realized I needed to do
some
some work uh and so we're both doing
therapy and it seems to be benefiting
well you're you're a beacon of light for
men who are
find themselves in in emotional
situations without the right tools in
the toolkit and you can do one of two
things you can just take up your toolkit
and go home or you can you can storm the
gates of hell and try to find more tools
and that's what you're doing man I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you amen thank
you it's awesome what's your household
incomes for
go 69
okay
um does she work outside the home
no we're we're both in our mid 70s no
we're both retired
oh boy
so there there's money there to take
care of the short-term stuff
the the I mean you mean money you have a
nest egg
uh we we still have some resources a
401k and I have some I have some money
in my account all the debts are in her
name what is the uh how much money is in
your account
forty five thousand dollars how much
money is in your 401k
I'm not counting these two installment
loans how much miscellaneous is there
the little credit card mosquitoes
yeah I'm gonna say nine ten thousand
okay all right
um
I've got an income tax refund check
coming in the 2000's gonna get knocked
off for that
and I would write a check out I would
write a check out of yours today and pay
off all the credit cards that leaves the
40 and close all the accounts okay now
that is a gesture on your part towards
the healing that you're searching for
the 40 is still sitting there we'll come
back to that in a minute then I want to
meet with her and her therapist and your
therapist and however y'all are doing
this marriage stuff and somehow you've
got to get some checks and balances and
start to incrementally rebuild trust
that you're not throwing good money
after bad this doesn't happen again
because in the back of your mind you're
if I clean this out and this happens
again I ain't got anywhere to go that's
what's happening in the back of your
mind so you've got to know that this is
solid going forward before you write any
more big checks
but nine thousand but nine thousand
dollars in the scope of your life you
would pay that right now for healing
and I would yeah yeah let's let's get
rid of all the mosquitoes get it down to
the 17 5 and 20. three five and then
let's just sit there with those two
while we work on this relationship and
as your trust reaches closer to 100
percent and that is going to require
some demonstrations as well as on her
part and your part in healing and some
time to rebuild and as that is rebuilt
and you approach 100 on that then I'm
gonna start trying to figure out a way
to get those paid off but right now I
want to clear the the white noise the
Clutter out of my mind with all these
little bills that because every time you
write a check on this it picks the scab
it opens the wound
and I'm trying to get it down to write
in just two checks
it's very perceptive you're right
yeah I mean I get pissed off all all
over again every time you do this and
you have to go through the whole process
you've been doing in therapy start
forgiveness again you start have to go
back through the whole thing and you
just you start having all these
conversations between your ears we all
do this that's how I know
I I wouldn't be guilty of it no not me
but yeah but I mean yeah you write
checks for things you're that remind you
of bad things it's bad so Dave at what
point
does and again in service of choosing
reality just owning this is where we
find ourselves do two people in their
70s
have to commit to going back to work for
a year and earn another forty thousand
dollars to pay these debts if she's of
good health
I mean I would talk to her therapist
about this I'm not going to intervene in
that but if she's of good health
um it sounds like both of them she's
trying to re-earn trust
and
um you know I'm 12 stepping here but uh
you know make them make good make amends
yeah I think she goes back to work yeah
and we start working on these other two
loans I I think that's not because of
financial but just I think that's a
representative movement towards owning
this it will give a place for that
energy me too you know you know make
amends it is a 12-step thing and so you
got to go back and where you can correct
the wrongs it's part of being repentant
or sorry
you know and nobody wants to work in
their 70s and that's where we find
ourselves right and nobody wants to get
scammed to buy a romance on the internet
that's where we find ourselves
this is the Ramsay show